[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous pensez des transports
en commun parisiens les transports en
commun je trouve ça
utile pour moi ouais pourquoi parce que
ça m'évite d'avoir une voiture je me
déplace très vite et votre frère il en
pense quoi
ça me fait elles sont pas là or là au
calme on est là ça vaut pas failli
magnifique c'est les données lissées
pour qui c'est pour cyril hanouna
qu'est ce que vous pensez transports en
commun parisiens
je trouve très efficace j'aime beaucoup
les transports en commun et je circule
beaucoup de à paris le quartier est
votre frère il en pense quoi
qui ça notre ère frère chez votre frère
c'est quoi ce truc des poignets sécurité
non mais de poids le transport oui ça
dessert de partout ça dessert de partout
ouais faut dire vrai on a même porté là
je prends n'importe quelle heure mais je
prends rarement et votre frère
ils en pensent quoi à mon frère faut
demander à ma mère qu'il n'a pas fait ou
qui l'a pas dit alors je trouve assez
bien répartis sur le territoire avec une
fréquence qui est quand même vraiment
intéressant parce que j'ai vu un petit
peu différente nous a confondu en fait
ont ils ont échangé les c2 reggina non
non non non plus pour des frangins ils
ont confondu gros sites et une calzone
c'est d'abord moi c'est la truffe et
celle ci je lâche pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]